es ist richtig dass die amerikaner in
ihrer grundsatzentscheidung im mai sich
gegen die anwendung von
wirkungsverstärker ausgesprochen haben
sie haben deswegen die traditionellen
impfstoff für die amerikanische
bevölkerung bestellt und diese
entscheidung leiden sie zurzeit weil sie
schlicht und einfach mit der impfstoff
produktion nicht hinterher kommen
deswegen hat der amerikanische präsident
obama verteilte der usa inzwischen den
notstand was die grippe situation angeht
ausgerufen weil man schlicht und einfach
die menschen nicht impfen kann die sich
gerne impfen lassen möchten so sehen sie
jede entscheidung hat ihre pros und cons
die amerikaner haben auf den verstärker
verzichtet deswegen haben sie weniger
impfstoff